this video is sponsored by brilliant
over the past four years I've been
making video blogs about my experiences
doing a PhD at the University of Exeter
and now that I'm finished I thought that
it might be fun to do an overall review
and talk about five things I liked and
five things I didn't like about doing my
PhD obviously this is gonna be specific
to my personal case and no two PhDs are
alike but I think the points are generic
to most PhDs and so they should still be
a help if you are considering doing one
or not however if you are a PhD student
watching this and you think I've missed
a particularly egregious pro or con then
please put that down in the comments
below like brexit I'm gonna kick
everything off with a big con and that's
not having any money if you're doing a
PhD in the UK then your typical stipend
is around fifteen thousand pounds
depending on whether you live in London
or not and so whilst I was doing my PhD
I was earning less than some of my
friends were paying in tax especially
seeing as I went to a well ranked
University and did a science degree a
lot of the people that I went to
undergraduate with were earning a lot of
money whilst I was earning not very much
money at all I've said in previous
videos that you shouldn't be doing a PhD
for financial reasons anyway but this is
a serious concern during your PhD you
you're not gonna have very much money
you're going to be living basically like
you did at undergraduate in similar
accommodation shopping at similar places
generally trying to avoid spending money
wherever possible this does pressurize
people to do work alongside their PhDs
for example marking or teaching or
tutoring or in my case youtubing most
people do this fine especially for the
first year or two but it is worth
pointing out that between the rigors of
doing the PhD and having to work on the
side you're not going to have very much
spare time and you're in a financial
situation where one catastrophic event
can tip you over the edge into some real
difficulties during my PhD I had a drone
related accident I went so any more than
that and I had to pay five hundred
pounds in damages which was a very big
ask and basically wiped out my reserves
had anything else happened after that I
would have been in serious trouble
so yes you don't do a PhD expecting to
earn very much money but you are going
to be operating on a very tight budget
and you're gonna perceive yourself to be
falling behind the friends that you went
school with me went to university with
in terms of finances okay to make things
more positive the first pro flexibility
this may be the case more for me than
some other PhDs because I was doing
basically a lot of coding I could work
anywhere with a laptop which meant I
could work at any time I didn't have to
go into the office I could work in
libraries or coffee shops and I could
come and go as I pleased other PhDs
notably those with lab components will
require you to come in on a regular
basis sometime in the middle of the
night but generally I think PhDs offer
more flexibility than a lot of other
jobs flexibility in terms of where and
when you work I could come in on the
weekends I could come in a middle of a
night if I wanted generally I kept
office hours because it was more
sociable that way but also flexibility
in what you did on a day-by-day basis I
was my own boss and I could determine
which tasks I thought always pressing
and do them in whatever way I saw fit
but more than that the self-directed
nature of the PhD meant that I could
pursue whatever I thought was
interesting if I came across an
interesting result that was a little bit
out of the ordinary and wasn't expected
I could just run down that rabbit hole
and pursue it and drop everything else
and I don't think there are many jobs
that allow you that kind of flexibility
comm number two being tied to your
supervisor
I accept that this can be very much a
pro or a con depending on how you work
with your supervisor and I can't stress
enough just how important the student
supervisor relationship is if you are
thinking of doing a PhD it is imperative
that you meet and have a chat with your
potential supervisor before applying
because whether or not you finish the
PhD and how much work you get done along
the way and how easy you find it along
the way is almost uniquely determined by
how good your supervisor is at their job
I know PhDs across the spectrum going
from people who had really experienced
supervisors he knew exactly what they
were doing from day one set out a plan
and then in three years the student just
did what they were told
coasted through really easy experience
but then on the other hand I've known
people who whose supervisors had never
supervised anyone before they were
unfamiliar with the systems and didn't
set a plan and so they were just left to
flounder around for three or four or
even more years not really know
what they were doing and even worse you
get people who just actively dislike
their supervisors and try not to meet
with them wherever possible and in some
cases you get supervisors who you just
never see because there's such high
profile academics they don't have time
for their students they're always away
on conferences and interesting places I
was somewhere in the middle on the
spectrum my supervisor was a very
respected scientist but he had never
supervised anyone before because he'd
been in private research rather than
university it meant that he had
fantastic scientific insights and a
great knows for what direction to go in
but I don't think I was given enough
direction from the get-go I think I was
allowed to fumble my way around and
decide what I thought was interesting
but that meant that it took longer for
me to complete my PhD then it would have
done competitive my friends for example
he was set that this is what you are
doing and I'm gonna sell tell you week
by week this is where I expect you to be
so this was only a con in my personal
case but I think it is a general con
that you are uniquely ties to somebody
else's abilities if things go really
wrong you can switch supervisors though
it is rare but by and large whether or
not you get your PhD is determined by
someone that you don't have a huge
amount of control over and I view that
as a con Pro number two something which
I've already alluded to the ability to
travel over the course of my PhD I have
been lucky enough to go to Vienna to San
Francisco so all over the UK to talk
about science talk about what I've been
doing my research and to learn what
other people have been doing and it's
been amazing academic conferences are
their own beasts and I may end up doing
a whole video about them anyway but once
you've been doing your research for a
while you build up a network of people
that you know from other universities
who you talk to on Twitter and these
conferences are a great way to network
and meet these people in real life and
these conferences tend to be in really
nice places like San Francisco Vienna
New Orleans Hawaii if you're an
astronomer and the best part of
traveling during the PhD is that as long
as you can justify going there for your
research the University will most likely
at least subsidize your travel if not
pay for it completely I've known PhD
students who were basically told look
just keep spending money on our travel
budget until the university tells us to
stop and so they basically had a free
ticket to travel wherever they wanted as
they could justify it in some way
perhaps this was a benefit of going to
Exeter compared to somewhere else but I
think generally doing a PhD is a great
way to travel see the world and meet
interesting people Khan number three
possibly the most obvious thing I'm ever
gonna say in a video PhDs are hard work
I went dwell on this too much because it
kind of speaks for itself but doing the
PhD is a lot of hours although I'd like
to draw a distinction between hard and
difficult when I started my PhD I went
to a training session and the lecturer
basically said look guys you're on the
course now it's actually quite difficult
to fail if you just do what you're told
and put the powers in what you're doing
doesn't necessarily have to be
technically difficult although generally
it will be what you're doing just takes
a lot of time for example a very good
friend of mine he in his PhD measured
glacial features Romaric Marines in
front of places doing that isn't
necessarily terribly difficult but he
had to do a lot off them and then he had
to do all the statistics all the
analysis write the software that did
analysis that nobody had done before all
this stuff which just takes time and
particularly in the run-up to submitting
your thesis you will almost certainly be
doing 12-hour days plus seven days a
week for possibly months on end after
people submit their theses they
generally take quite a bit of time off
like weeks or months of not doing very
much so they can physically recover from
what they've put their body through it
is hard to do a PhD particularly at the
end so don't do one if you think it's
just gonna be an easy ride and better
than getting a real job okay Pro number
three improving your skills in the same
way that you don't just do an
undergraduate for the knowledge that you
get in your degree you do it for the way
it teaches you to think and the skills
it teaches you a PhD is a fantastic way
of expanding what you're capable of
doing in my personal case that meant
getting so much better at programming I
was given a lot of support by the other
guys in my office and by training
courses in how to code in Python yes I
could have done this on my own in my own
time if I was doing some other job but
in this case I was trained how to do it
and I learned on the job by being given
lots of research problems to do I don't
even know how many programs I wrote in
the end and so doing the PhD gave me a
technical transferable skill and I feel
like that's common to
pretty much all phd's it might not be
coding but it could be analysis
problem-solving statistics all these
skills which are immensely transferable
if you wish to work on something else
after you graduates but more than that
and more than these soft skills that you
get like interpersonal skills and
presentation skills because you will
have to present your research at some
point more than that you are given the
ability to manage an immensely
complicated project on your own with
support from your supervisor yes but on
your own and bring it to completion
normally vaguely on schedule a phrase
which I really like is that we're all
prisoners of our previous reference
points and once you've submitted a
thesis and you've seen the complexity of
the whole project on your own you kind
of have the confidence you see that it
is possible to do something like that
again of your own volition it gives you
a huge amount of confidence and skill in
bringing a very big project they do it
bigger than you previously conceived was
even possible to fruition that might be
doing stuff outside of work like writing
a novel in your spare time or it could
be work project if you leave academia
but it's a very very valuable skill
alongside all the other technical and
soft skills which you were given during
the PhD and I view that as a huge huge
benefit
however call number four you might well
be pigeonholed there seems to be some
kind of assumption that people who
graduate with PhDs are incredibly
skilled at that one thing and nothing
else this as I just said is completely
untrue PhD graduates have a huge number
of transferable skills they're capable
of doing things in a wide variety of
fields I've known people who have
graduated from their PhDs and then
stayed in academia but moved to a
completely different field like from
physics to biology I've known people who
have graduated left academia behind
completely and then gone on to do
something wildly different but uses the
same skills like data analysis or
machine learning so while you're not
actually over specialized people will
perceive you as being over specialized
and they will pigeonhole you in one
particular field and that's something
which some people some recruiters will
do and others won't but it is worth
bearing in mind if you're doing a PhD
that you might be limiting your options
in some way
unless you can demonstrate to them that
you are capable of doing things outside
of your field in my particular case yes
I have my PhD in atmospheric physics and
my physics degree but I also have a wide
portfolio of video editing and have a
wide portfolio of talks which I've given
I've basically demonstrated that yes I
do that but also other things so a con
yes but not as big of a problem as I
think a lot of people perceive it to be
Pro number four contributing to human
knowledge one of the key requirements of
doing a PhD is that you have done some
original research you have pushed the
boundaries of human knowledge and that
is the coolest thing I've done things
I've learned things which nobody has
done before I uncovered a phenomenon in
my thesis that was completely unknown
before the examiners were like ah that's
that's really cool and if that idea
doesn't excite you then maybe you
shouldn't be doing a PhD at all because
to me that is incredible depending on
your philosophy doing a PhD in and
expanding the frontier of human
knowledge is kind of the most important
thing you can do with your life you're
leaving the state of how we understand
the world better than it was before you
were born so philosophy depend on the
work you do in the PhD if you then don't
go into academia afterwards could well
be your biggest contribution to the
world and I feel like that's a pretty
big Pro however con number-5 it can be
incredibly isolating going from the
ecstasy of talking about how awesome
doing the PhD is the end of the day it
is very hard as I've already said not
just physically but mentally rates of
mental health problems in PhD students
is definitely higher than the national
average and that's because you're doing
a very hard piece of work you're doing
something that is intensely stressful
and you're doing it mostly alone you
argument support by your supervisors and
your research group if you're working in
a research group but at the end of the
day you are the captain of the ship with
basically no crew you will have to do
everything yourself
nobody else on the planet apart from
maybe a couple of people really
understands the details of what you're
doing and so you can feel very isolated
during my PhD I was so stressed that I
actually developed a psychosomatic
breathing problems meaning that I felt
like I couldn't breathe even though
there was nothing physically
wrong with me but my brain was basically
shutting my lungs down that may be more
of an extreme case than most PhDs but I
will guarantee you if you talk to pretty
much any PhD student they will have a
vaguely similar story about their near
breaking point of stress of the times
when they thought they were just
completely overwhelmed and pretty much
everybody at some point just goes home
and cries their eyes out your research
is Australian not just on you but also
on your friends and on your
relationships and you have to be really
committed to it I think to make it
through there's really no way of
sugarcoating it doing a PhD is hard
mentally and physically and there are a
whole worlds of hurts that you can
expose yourself to if you overdo it and
if you don't identify useful good
support structures but Pro number five
you spend another three or four years at
the University and with that comes a
huge number of support structures yes
you've got the university mental health
services and the the doctors on campus
but you also have a readily available
friendship group in my case I really
didn't have a good time as an
undergraduate I worked way too hard I
got myself incredibly stressed I had
mental health problems which prevented
me from doing as well as I could have
done and so when I started my PhD I very
much perceived it as a chance to have a
second bite at the Apple a second crack
doing University and this time round I
definitely did it much better because I
ended up with a fantastic group of
friends in my case it was from the
chapel choir that I sang in from all the
music side of campus I had a great
support network friends that was
ready-made by the university system
having now left University it's only now
that I realize how special it is to be
at uni because if you say graduate and
move to a new town how do you make new
friends
yes there are societies and things like
that but that's very much a lot of
effort on your part you will go out and
seek out those societies and those
people whereas at university every year
there's a freshers fair saying hey if
you're interested in this thing come and
have a chat to us if you like singing
come and have a chat to us if you like
playing rugby go and have a go over
there to the sports stores the
university system allows you to meet
people and do things which you can do
outside yes
life much much easier and in exodus case
there was a campus cinema there were
opportunities to make music and play
sport and all these things which were
special to being University and the fact
is by doing a PhD you have another few
years of making the most of those
advantages for me the benefits were
mostly social but whatever it is that
you want to get out of life I think
being a university just makes it that
little bit easier and it certainly made
me much much happier so for those of you
who wish to weigh up the pros and cons
of doing a PhD this is my personal take
however if you're not yet in a position
to consider doing a PhD or if you're
just curious about expanding your
horizons and learning new skills then I
definitely recommend checking out
brilliant dog who were kind enough to
sponsor this video if you've seen a
science YouTube video before then you've
probably seen an advert spot like this
where you get someone like me telling
you about a product or a service or a
website but to me brilliant dog is
different because it's based on an
educational philosophy that I firmly
believe it but the best way to learn
something is to get stuck in and try
your hand at it and make mistakes and
learn from those mistakes
brilliant has courses on everything from
foundational maths and science right the
way up to complicated topics like
machine learning I've taken these
courses myself I can tell you they're
really good as well as the courses you
also have problems of the week set by
they're incredibly engaged community and
generally the website is a fantastic
educational resource that I wish I had
access to when I was applying to
university because it would have made me
a stronger student you can use parts of
the website for free but if you'd like
to get access to the premium courses
then you need a premium subscription and
if you'd like one of those and go to the
link in the description brilliant org
forward slash Simon Clark and you can
get 20% off your premium and your
subscription and support this channel
thank you for watching the video and for
making it all the way to the end if
you're interested in the vlogs I made
whilst I was doing my PhD then they'll
be a link up here from the very
beginning to the very ends and like 70
blocks and yeah I had some good times
and some bad ones I'll leave you to
watch them thanks for watching I'll see
you in the next one